neue corona varianten immer neue
impfstoffe immer wieder impfen impfen
impfen wird das unser leben fragen wir
den virologen klaus stöhr heute früh
hierbei bild live schönen guten tag herr
professor stört also wird unser leben so
aussehen alle drei oder sechs monate
immer wieder impfen impfen weil immer
neue varianten auftauchen die kurze
antwort lautet nein
sie haben vielleicht den chef von beyond
etwas verkürzt zitiert er hat natürlich
gesagt dass es unter umständen könnte
dass man alle drei monate vielleicht
muss dann muss aber das ist ja so allein
für sich stehend nicht richtig was
richtig ist ist dass ältere die jetzt
werden würden dich boostern lassen
würden noch einen guten schritt haben
wären auch gegen omikron über die
nächsten drei vier fünf monate bei
jüngeren würde der impfschutz sogar noch
länger halten und über den nächsten
sommer hinweg auch keine impfung
aufgefrischt werden der infektions punkt
wirklich gering seien 10 bis 15 mal
geringer als jetzt das hat man im
letzten winter gesehen mit mit der cola
virus und in allen vielen wintern davor
mit den art mix erkrankung und im
nächsten herbst wird es nur sein dass
die berechtigt jährigen aber auch
honorable diabetespatienten patienten
mit chronisch obstruktiver pneumonie
raucher übergewichtige sicherlich und
der impfung profitieren werden und die
sollten sich dann noch mal pusten lassen
aber jetzt alle drei monate bewusst das
ist ein bisschen verkürzt zitiert haben
verkehr zitiert wir haben das zitat kurz
gemacht aber nicht verkürzt herr
beherrschen sagt nehme er rät jetzt
schon nach drei monaten wieder zu
boostern er hat das nicht
verallgemeinern nicht für die zukunft
gesagt das haben wir nicht gesagt wir
haben die frage daraus abgeleitet wird
jetzt unser leben so aussehen also
brauchen wir jetzt alle 36 monate in
frischen booster das sagen sie ganz klar
nein das war kurz zitiert aber nicht
verkürzt zitiert ja entschuldigung ja
ich würde jetzt über das nicht hier
falsch falsch interpretiert willst dann
aber es ist tatsächlich so wer sich im
vor den letzten drei vier fünf monaten
hat wuchern lassen und unter 60 ist also
eine sehr geringe chance eigentlich hat
schwer zu erkranken
der sollte sich das überlegen vielleicht
noch mal vor dem westen
fünf sechs monate um nochmal boostern zu
lassen auf jeden fall wer allerdings
über rechtliche und gleichwohl habe und
die letzten drei vier fünf monate
zurückliegt die impfung hatte denn die
letzte der 2 anfänglichen impfung der
sollte sich auch noch mal pusten lassen
letztendlich kann jetzt jeder von dem
booster profitieren die älteren vielmehr
die jüngeren auch noch natürlich aber
dass man jetzt glaubt wer jetzt den
booster hatten vielleicht vor vier
wochen oder vor einem monat hat er nicht
in diesem winter noch zweimal bus
verlassen muss das wird nicht der fall
sein und man darf auch nicht vergessen
die impfung jetzt ist ja impfstoff
enthält genetische sequenzen von einem
früheren
während dieser impfstoff schützt gut
gegen delta aber auch offiziell wird
dagegen konnte nicht nur weil die
antikörper dagegen schützen aber auch
die anderen bollwerke der immunität und
wenn man jetzt eine frische impfung hat
wenn die antikörper sehr hoch sind dann
wird es natürlich sehr gut schützen
gegen delta und auch noch relativ gut
gegen und deswegen ist es jetzt richtig
zu sagen für alle lasst euch ein paar
boostern
jemand ja jetzt vor zwei wochen deine
letzte impfung alle braucht das jetzt
nicht gleich wieder zu machen ja könnte
sich dann überlegen je nachdem wie die
situation sich entwickelt vielleicht im
nächsten jahr noch mal im winter oder
vielleicht sogar wenn der frische
impfstoff kommendem april mai aber ich
kann mir das muss ich ehrlich sagen
nicht vorstellen dass dann im april mai
noch ein booster notwendig sein würde so
kurz vorm sommer ist dann auch sehr
viele menschen dann noch die natürliche
immunität draufgesattelt bekommen haben
auch gegen den den impfstoff also jetzt
boostern lassen und dann wird
höchstwahrscheinlich durch den ganzen
winter durch reichen also ein vorsichtig
optimistischer ausblick zumindest in den
frühling vielen herzlichen dank ihnen